the Joe Rogan experience speaking of
social media I just got a huge did you
see that I just got hacked
did you really get out or like no I got
hacked Ali still your manager what I
thought I thought Ali did that and look
you got a hat but if you know but if you
if you know let's you know the foot when
I start with the first man yeah when I
you definitely got hacked I would tell
you if you guys Ali Ali tell you it
ollie lie to you no Holly didn't lie to
me because the crazy thing is the crazy
thing is were were we were we were
preparing to go to the fight we would
like to they were coming to get us
because the fights already started the
prelims had started and he was about to
start the main car so we're preparing to
go as a Saturday and you know my phone
was just bloop bloop I'm getting text
message text message text message
I'm excite maybe it's just one person
you want to get there I'm down because
my phone just blows up sometimes so I'm
not really looking at my phone I'm just
trying to get out of there and go and I
somehow I I just I picked my phone up
we're getting walking down to the car I
slide it up and I have 26 messages what
just happened so and then the top one
was a what's her name page you know I
used to work for the Aussies I uh are
you looking at your Twitter right now
like what what are you talking about is
I yeah this is like what I thought I
thought you you something's wrong with
your Twitter right now you need to get
on there so I'm like what I get on my
phone I try to go into my Twitter I
can't I'm locked out so someone had got
in and changed the password in the email
so I can't even get into my Twitter and
and then I'm with Ali cuz he's with me
and we're walking down
I'm not yo Ali you know I need to see
your phone now I need to see your phone
because I can't even see what they were
tweeting and so I get his phone and I go
to my page and the first couple that the
first like the first one was like it was
wrong and it on so many levels was kind
of funny if you aren't troll you know
but he was tweeting Connor he was like
I'm gonna be raw doggin to do something
with your wife tonight I was
oh well that's a little you know that's
a little much you know and then the next
one cut another one comes in another one
comes in another I'm like and now he's
going all the way left and now he's he
at one point even said something by Mike
Tyson your n-word like you effing n-word
you this he said to Mike Tyson yeah so
he's tweeting - a bunny nice tweeting to
a bunch of people like you you know your
effing n-word or this and that like like
going in like that oh and then scre
screen screen screen shots my bank
account somehow he gets got into my bank
account got into my bank account and
screenshots it and puts it out now I'm
getting like messages like yo what is
going like and then of course that was
right there on my old they got my bank
account boom I called the bank I'm on
the phone my bank and we're in the car
going to the arena to Connors fight and
now Dana we're getting calls from a
message from everybody like yo we would
now the UFC's working on getting a
Twitter shut down and by the time they
called and got the Twitter shut down he
had tweeted my bank you know screenshot
my bank accounts he'd you know they
tweeted you know the random people a lot
of disrespectful things he was like oh
he was I want one tweet he was like you
know if I get over a hundred thousand
followers or a thousand comments or
retweets on this I'm gonna put his
peanut pincode out or is like internet
password the password for that out there
Mike stuff cuz I have my phone right
like how did they get in to my stuff and
I have everything now Instagram they
shut down my Instagram right away before
he could post anything you know because
that I have a lot more followers on
there and it was just like I was so like
just just flustered by it all to where I
couldn't do anything but smile like I
just does anybody ever post for you oh
yeah it used to they used to yeah but I
I'm I still like to have some level of
control but meaning that other people
besides you have your password yeah yeah
yeah but it's it's it's someone that I
know someone that I trust
you know it's not like random people
know it's one purchase but one person
but is it possible to that one person
left their phone laying around or
something and someone saw the password
no no because now it candy because he
wasn't just my Twitter they got my bank
account right that's what's crazy I mean
I don't how are they connected how's the
bank account and the Twitter and from
when I'm learning now is they can easy
hackers can easily hack you from it I
like your Starbucks Wi-Fi they can yeah
that's why yeah do you want a virtual
private network a VPN
yeah we use expressvpn but there's a
bunch of them you you could use that and
the good thing about it is also you
could get into accounts like you could
do stuff like you know you're in other
countries they lock you out of things
yeah
like you can't look at certain parts of
the web you can if you have a VPN yeah
because this this was what and obviously
something they were using because you
know they sign when they sign in to my
they tried to get into my my email they
got into money when he sign in because
now you have that two-factor
authentication or whatever and when they
sign it show one of them showed that
they were in New York another one showed
that they were in like Bali mm-hmm so
they were switching up yeah yeah whoever
knew what they were they knew what they
were doing because they were they were
getting in there saying some and it was
like and of course and I saw that and
and it was unfair to to my manager for
people to actually say that because you
know a lot of math leads everybody soon
of course everyone say and then Connor
said something about it too which was
kind of which was very low I understand
that the comments that were tweeted out
we're very very disrespectful first of
all that's not me I don't need to talk
like of course you know and I would
never say anything like that if you know
as much as I want to beat him up you
feed Connor wants to fight we can fight
it but I would never there's lines that
you don't cross that's not you at all I
would listen ever you saying that you're
so like effing you know yeah I mean
don't get me wrong I say you know of
course yeah yeah you know but it was
just I would never say anything about
someone to family someone's wife someone
or so children I would never say that no
I I never thought for a second it was
you and an ally is a guy thats so into
his friend would never say I don't care
how much he hates Connor or how much
I thought he was just trying to stir up
the pot now no yeah well I didn't know
the extent of course not I didn't know
the extent of what he'd said either I
didn't know people it's bad it was bad
it was some of the things when they find
out who did it is it their way do you
know I would think so but you know it's
I'm sure that's something like that's
gonna be expensive
mmm you know someone's got to
investigate that tell the UFC pony up
but you know my mom you know is it is it
worth it for them to do it if it is if
it's Olly
that's sure that's the only way it's
worth it that's true if it's just some
random crazy dude some Russian hat
that's not worth it but that's what
that's insane in order to find out if
it's worth it or not you got to do the
investigation you got to pay for all of
that yeah but I stay away the funny
thing is as soon as we get laid and it
comes up in ziko initially I didn't know
what he meant but he was like I was like
yeah I talked to I had to talk with him
like you know I made sure everything was
okay and I'm thinking like gotta talk
with who would he talk and and this was
before I really saw the tweets he's like
you had to talk with Connor I'm thinking
like mushy [ __ ] about Connor
I got hacked were you talking about
right until I saw the comments and what
was said towards him I was like oh [ __ ]
okay I understand this guy's going into
one of the biggest fights I mean he's
this is a return fight you know with
everything he's gone through and having
that hanging around or someone saying of
course yeah it's just first of all we're
not that thirsty I'm the champion the
belts gonna move I'm gonna fight
somebody yeah you know so I don't really
care who it is I'm gonna fight somebody
[Applause]